many teachers have a poor work/life
balance I know because I've had years of
experience as a teacher in the classroom
I'm here to teach you how to handle your
workload and restore that work-life
balance if you follow my time management
methods long days should be a thing of
the past you'll be able to go home on
time where we free knowing that you've
done everything you need to do let's
begin one of the biggest challenges you
face as a teacher is your uncooperative
co-workers your students sometimes they
try and do as little work as is possible
and it can be tempting to let them get
away with it
after all if some of them don't do their
homework that's less homework for you to
mark small problems like this such as
letting an individual student get away
with not doing a homework or a project
can quickly grow into big problems like
the entire class not doing their
homework ultimately if the students
aren't doing the work you're assigning
them they're going to do less well in
the tests and they're learning less you
also have to spend more and more time in
your day dealing with classroom
management issues like trying to get
them to do their work the students don't
learn just what you teach them directly
they're also learning about you as a
person if you're the kind of teacher who
lets homework slide they're going to be
less and less likely to do work for you
and to respect you you have to make sure
that you're keeping track of everything
that's going on in your classroom but
this is quite a challenge because often
times teachers have 500 or more students
that they need to be looking after how
do you make sure that you're keeping
track of what everybody owes you and
what needs to be done the tool that I
recommend that can change your life is
just a small sturdy clipboard if you go
out and you get one for yourself today I
guarantee you it'll change your life as
a teacher there are three kinds of
things that you should keep on your
clipboard their tracking sheets their
daily must do lists and there's a
general to-do list I want to talk about
the tracking sheet first the tracking
sheet starts out its life is just a
plain piece of blank paper but as the
days go by if any student misses
something for you
a homework or a project you put their
name on this list make a note of what
the thing is that they're missing and
the date that this happened on you
should go through this list at least
once a week and cross off anybody who's
gotten work back to you or send messages
to those who haven't if a student
continues now to give something to you
you need to look into your own school
sanctions policies as long as you never
cross off anybody's name before they've
given you what they owe you
you'll always be making sure that you
get every piece of work from every
student when collecting in the homework
from students you should go around to
the students desk
individually collect each piece of
homework and then write down the names
of those
you don't have it if you do this
regularly the students will quickly
learn that you're the kind of teacher
who doesn't let things slide and they'll
put you on the top of their own to-do
lists the second thing to talk about are
the daily must do lists on your computer
you should make a Word document that has
a blank page for each workday on those
pages you're going to put down the
things that must happen by the end of
that day in order to be fully prepared
for the next day so as an example every
Monday you need to list all of the
classes that you need to plan for on
Tuesday if there's anything else that
needs to be done before Tuesday also put
that on that list the thing that really
makes this work is that it is a must-do
list this is not a daily to-do list
you're not putting down things that you
would like to get done by the end of the
day but that are ultimately optional you
need to put down things that have to get
done I like to think of this as my I
must do this before I can go home list
if you limit your list to only the
things that absolutely have to get done
it's much more motivating to knock those
things off so you know you can go home
at the end of the day and not have to be
worrying all night about what you need
to do first thing in the morning to be
ready for the day the last thing to keep
on the clipboard is a general to-do list
this is a list for everything that
doesn't fit on your must do lists
anything that is less time-sensitive
goes on here any general project that
you need to do at some point but not by
a specific day will all be kept track of
on here after you've crossed off your
must do list then you would turn over to
your general to-do list and start
working through those items if you have
time the next thing I want to talk about
is paperwork teachers deal with a lot of
paper and you have to have a system for
keeping it all together this is what I
recommend you should have one folder for
each class that you teach within that
folder you're going to keep all of the
papers that you currently need to teach
that class so any worksheets that you're
going to give out any tests you're going
to give out homework that you've gotten
back and need to mark all of those kinds
of things go into this folder any
reference materials that you wouldn't
need on a particular day to teach that
class such as workbooks that you use to
photocopy the worksheets from those you
can keep in a separate filing cabinet
here's an example of the kind of thing
to keep inside one of the folders this
is a collection of papers it's for a
year ten tests there's three parts to
this little packet so let's take a look
at them first there's the papers
themselves
secondly there's a title sheet that
clearly describes what they are in this
example year 10 tests and lastly there's
a coverslip which keeps all of these
things together if you leave a lot of
blank space in your cover sheet you can
add additional information later on such
as when you've given the test to the
students and received them back you can
add to mark on the front of that sheet
so that you know you need to take care
of this and once you've marked them you
can then cross that out again to quickly
review keep one folder for each of your
classes and keep all of the things that
you need to teach that class in that
folder once you set up the system you
know that you just need that single
folder to be adequately prepared for the
class this is also convenient in case
there's a room change you can just grab
that folder and go if you're able to
organize your files in the way that I've
just recommended and you're able to
consistently work with your daily
must-do list the advantage is that when
you walk into school on any day you know
that you're completely ready for
whatever is going to happen you don't
have to spend any of your day
frantically planning for that afternoon
lesson and if anything comes up
unexpectedly you don't have to worry
about it because you're all set for
every one of your lessons for that day
once you start getting used to this
ready position you'll find that you have
more time in the day than you actually
originally thought one of the places
that time has been hiding from you is in
these little five-minute intervals
between lessons after the last class
leaves and before the next class comes
in you can use this time in a productive
way if you're prepared adequately I
recommend that you keep a list of things
that you can do in these little
five-minute times for example you can do
some quick filing or if you have an easy
to mark quiz you can mark a couple of
pages in that quiz after a full day of
teaching you can sometimes find that
you've marked a complete class set of
quizzes without ever feeling like you
had to sit down and mark the whole thing
at once I want you to realize as a
teacher that your job is a lot less
clear than other jobs if you think of a
factory worker they have a clearly
defined shift which is 9:00 to 5:00 and
they're producing a tangible product
such as a car you know when the car is
done because all of the pieces have been
fit together being a teacher is not like
this if you're working on something like
making presentations or making a test
for a class or a worksheet this kind of
work can really go on forever you can
always make a presentation a little bit
snappier or you can always make a
worksheet a little bit clearer when
you're making something like a worksheet
at some point the worksheet is going to
be serviceable
is going to be completely adequate for
the educational aim that you're trying
to achieve if you're going to continue
working you really need to stop and
think for a moment would I better spend
my time making this worksheet absolutely
perfect or would my time be better spent
moving on to something else most of the
time the answer is the latter you're
better off having two satisfactory
worksheets for two different classes
than one perfect worksheet for one class
but no worksheet for the other one now
let's talk about sick days teachers have
one of the lowest absentee rates of any
profession and I don't think that's
because teachers are more healthy than
most people it's because as a teacher
sometimes missing a day of work is more
of a hassle than just going in no matter
how poorly you may be feeling because of
this teachers don't often take days off
work until they're feeling really poor
do yourself a favor as a teacher
spend some time creating lessons to be
used in your absence ahead of time if
you make them before you need them when
you actually are sick you can just call
in the school and tell them there's a
file in my filing cabinet
it's called cover work everything you
need is in there and you can hang up the
phone crawl back into bed and spend your
day getting better as opposed to
spending your day worrying about what
your students are actually going to do
the last thing I want to talk about is
how big projects get done something like
a cathedral doesn't just pop into
existence it gets built very slowly over
time one brick by one brick it's a good
idea to try and carve out at least 20
minutes maybe 30 minutes every day to
work on a long-term project that's
beneficial to you and your career for
example if there's a new computer skill
that you need to learn if you just spend
20 minutes a day on it you can make real
progress on something like that over
time if you set aside daily time to work
on your long-term projects you'll be
pleasantly surprised by how much you can
accomplish when you look back in six
months or a year you'll be amazed at
what you've done and lastly don't forget
why it is you became a teacher in the
first place the summer holidays